hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going over the third arc of
chainsaw man the absolutely mind-bending
and time-warping eternity devil arc this
part of the story really takes off and
starts showing us a much much bigger
picture now as we are introduced to
again more characters abilities and left
on the biggest cliffhanger so far
throughout the manga so quickly if you
are interested in more story-styled
anime content just like this then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps with pushing my
stuff to a bunch of new amazing people
but anyway enough of that let's get into
the eternity devil arc of chainsaw man
so we start off with dingy sitting there
on the floor completely shocked by
marcum's offer to grant him any wish
stunned he insists to make sure she
isn't tripping when makima cuts him off
telling dingy that the devil is so
strong and evil that it is okay to offer
him a completely blank check she
continues on explaining that 13 years
ago the world was different as they
tried to use guns to counter devils
however due to an excess use of guns and
firearms both in devil hunting and in
the wider world with robberies and
murder fare over weapons began to build
and on the day of a major terrorist
incident in the usa the gun devil
suddenly appeared as we flow 13 years
back in time to a flashback with a young
boy who's reading with his parents we
find his older brother standing there in
the doorway asking to play catch with
their father in the snow but he tells
him that his younger brother isn't
feeling well and will have to do
something by himself which aggravates
the young boy as he says that his father
always says that they begin to argue but
tayo the younger brother says that he
would like to play with his older
brother as they step outside their
parents tell them to come back if they
get cold and once out the older brother
demands that tayo stop following him as
he is annoying however as he goes to
throw a snowball at his brother taiyo
launches one at him first and hits him
square in the face afterwards he notes
how cold his hands are and his brother
tells him to go grab his gloves from
inside the house so that they don't get
colder the younger brother runs off
happily towards the house and as tayo
re-enters sadly and seemingly in an
instant both he and the belding are
obliterated by the gun devil's blast it
is explained that on november the 18th
1984 at 10 am the gun devil hit japan
for 26 seconds and completely
obliterated a total of 57
912 men women and children elsewhere
throughout the world the death was
unparalleled with the us alone having
over 500 thousand deaths and china
another three hundred thousand when the
total numbers were finally calculated it
was revealed that in about five minutes
the gun devil had almost killed 1.2
million people around the globe then
completely disappeared and has never
been seen since back in the present
mahima explains that the gun devil has
been missing since leading to a banning
on all firearms globally as well as an
increase in the power of all devils due
to the heightened climate of fear trying
to take all this news in denji admits he
struggled to follow along to makima's
story and that the devil sounds too
strong to even comprehend but even so he
still confidently declares that he'll
beat the gun devil if he tries super
duper hard then she then asks her how
exactly he is going to find this thing
to which makima shows him that small
chunks of the gun devil's body were left
as residue after its attack as it moved
so fast that its body burned parts off
she says that when any devil eats these
pieces their powers are enhanced but if
you put these pieces together they begin
attaching apparently the gun devil is so
strong that when the pieces of its flesh
combine to a certain size they'll try to
return to its body and regenerate so
pretty much if they just continue to
chunk morbids together they'll
eventually be able to locate the gun
devil we then skip over to aki and
hirmino who were recovering a piece of
the gun devil that had been eaten by a
small fry devil as the two chair about
the meaning of their mission it is
revealed that the older brother in the
flashback was indeed aki hayakawa now on
his next mission denji alongside several
other hunters such as power aki and
himino are instructed to hunt a powerful
devil who had already killed many
civilian devil hunters that had
attempted to exterminate it aki states
that there has been movement from a gun
devil peace so it is likely that a devil
has ingested another part of it the
group approaches the hotel dingy and
power begin verbally harassing aki but
acquiescent when he offers them both a
gum for their silence araya expresses
are just trust over denji and power's
presence however aki reassures him that
they're merely there to aid and slain
the devil and if either of them step out
of line they'll be killed power and
dingy begin bickering saying that the
reason he's so annoyed must have been
because of the prank that they played on
him earlier in the day overhearing them
aki explodes in anger telling them that
the prank went way too far surprised at
his outburst hemingw tells him that he
can't be strict with him all the time
with danji agreeing so in order to ease
the tension she promises to give
whomever kills the devil a kiss on the
cheek ariah is shocked that a young
woman like himino would give himself
away before marriage and denji also
refuses her claiming that he has already
decided who his first kiss is going to
be first though he is simply going to
collect these meat chunks and then kill
the gun devil argue responds intensely
wondering if he really could kill the
gun devil and tamino says that that was
pretty ballsy to say in front of aki
then she also brings up that naughty
stuff feels best the more you know your
partner and he doesn't even know her
name yet he himenu playfully rebuffs him
promising him a french kiss if he kills
the devil to which denji reacts
excitedly panting like a dog further in
the hotel their group moves through the
corridors as denji and durai begin
arguing arai manages to pin denji to the
wall in an attempt to stop him from
reaching the devil first saying that he
won't let some punk steal her lips while
this happens aki and himino discuss the
other members of the team himino says
that arai has a strong drive but lacks
power whereas kabini is the opposite
she's timid but strong aki says the
blood thing is also strong but it's
possible she'll still betray them
however when it comes to dingy he still
doesn't know what his potential truly is
ximena asks if he thinks that the
newbies will be able to survive but he
instead just gives her a vague response
about how they may end up dead or at the
civilian sector soon enough hearing her
question get dodged himeno instead
orders aki not to die which is we find
instantly after in a flashback where the
two first meet it's revealed that aki is
himino's sixth partner and all of her
other ones had died because they were
useless no bodies but one of the first
things she ever said to him was to not
die back in the present himeno senses a
nearby presence and tells aki that it is
approaching them a room door then opens
and a small demon made up of only a head
one hand and a foot runs out in front of
them the small fleshy creature leaps at
kabini but is locked in place by hamino
and the power of the ghost devil power
then cheekily slices the creature in
half saying that the damn devil froze in
miriam out of fear of her but hermino
explains that her power was actually the
real reason similar to aki she gave her
right eye in order to use the ghost
devil's invisible right hand aki then
confirms that the devil they just slayed
wasn't the one and the group continues
upstairs
as they walk power playfully threatens
them saying they shouldn't blabber about
their powers in front of her but hermino
says it'll be easier to work as a team
if they know each other's powers plus
she has a trump card either way power
then points her blood blade at this
scared girl only for himino to
cheerfully grab her throat with a ghost
devil commanding the fiend to put the
weapon away which she does as the group
reaches the top of the stairs orion
notices that despite moving towards the
9th floor the sign shows them still
being on the 8th running downstairs to
check arise suddenly appears at the top
of the staircase the group tests the
theory with aki moving through rooms and
discovering that they are concurrent
their group concludes that they are
trapped on the eighth floor somehow and
aki breaks down the situation so that
they all understand no matter what they
do they cannot escape every single exit
they try to use results with them ending
back in the same location which is
likely due to the handiwork of a devil
hearing this dingy remarks that it's
power's fault as he bets the devil she
apparently killed trapped them there
upon its death however aki states that a
devil's powers are undone when they die
so that would be impossible as their
group comes to the realization that they
walked into a trap awry brings up how
other devil hunters will come and rescue
them after hq doesn't hear back for a
few hours because of this kabini begins
to panic though and goes on about how
she never wanted to join the devil
hunters and would have rather gone to
college instead while confronting kabini
himino notices a puzzled look on aki's
face he notes that all the clocks in the
room have stopped at 8 18 theorising
that the floor is trapped in time making
the rescue impossible everyone is left
shocked by the news apart from dengi who
instead is delighted by the lack of time
constraints choosing to take a nap a
rybarates him but denji shrugs it off
and instead tells them to wake him when
they figure it out he then calmly falls
asleep much to the shock of the group
himino reawakens dinji and informs him
that they are still stuck while he was
asleep they found out that the power and
water still works but when it comes to
food they have an extremely limited
supply aki has continued to hunt for the
devil arya has grown restless and closed
himself away in the covers and cabinet
was forcibly knocked out after
attempting to drink water from the
toilet when it comes to the feign ximena
presumes power is equally unhinged
however denji notes that she always acts
bizarrely was the trio guard the room
for orion cabinet ximena explains that
it's great to have an addiction as
you'll need something in life to take
the edge off then she notices the smoke
she has and says it's the same brand
that aki smokes to which hermine reveals
that she gave him an appreciation for
cigarettes as we go into a flashback we
find a younger aki and himino discussing
the reason he became a public safety
devil hunter himeno guesses correctly
that it's because of the gun devil and
states that devil hunters don't live
long anyway so it's not like smoking is
going to kill you aki states though that
he won't bite it so easily to which she
replies that he better not as it's a
hassle when her buddies die as the peer
walk outside himino is approached by a
woman who suddenly slaps her after the
woman leaves hemino discloses that she
was her previous buddy's girlfriend she
says she has come to expect such abuse
as a way for the grieving families to
vent their frustration
however not happy at this aki in
retaliation sticks gum on the girl's
clothes as he tries to justify why
himino bursts out laughing later on at a
nearby diner emino tells aki that he
reminds her of something her master
always says the devil hunters that the
devils fear the most aren't the
strongest or the brave they're afraid of
the ones but they few screws loose and
she thinks that he'll live for a long
while because of this she manages to
manipulate arki into picking up a smoke
which over time has become a symbol of
their friendship in the present aki
returns asking him if she has any smokes
left to which she states that this is
her last one as the two addicts share in
the butt of a smoke dengue pipes up
saying that that was an indirect kiss to
which he is told to shut up as aki
reveals that he has discovered the devil
that they have been searching for he
reminds them of the devil power had just
killed however now rather than just a
small humanist shape it took before it
is multiplied into a large and imposing
wall of flesh outside of the room the
devil mocks the group before offering
them an extremely enticing contract let
me eat the human name denji dead or
alive feed him to me and if they follow
the contract rules they will be returned
unharmed suddenly the door opens with
cabinet walking out holding a knife and
demanding that denji lets the massive
pile of flesh eat him aki and himino
immediately subdue kabimi kicking the
knife out of her hand and whacking her
to the floor himeno tells aki to summon
his fox but it is unsuccessful due to
the severed link with the outside world
amino uses a ghost to attack the devil
which inflicts pain however it grows in
size with each attack enveloping more of
the hallway and grabbing at her the
devil says that it is no use as its weak
point is not on the eighth floor and
that this is actually the inside of its
stomach so making a contract with him is
the only way to escape himeno explains
that a devil's contract is unbreakable
meaning that if a devil did not fulfill
its end deal it would die as such
allowing denji to die would guarantee
the other safety hearing this arrivos
that they let dingy be consumed aki
refuses though he argues that the devil
likely has an ulterior motive behind
specifically denji's death to which
himeno agrees as well power casually
votes to kill denchi only for aki to
explain that as a fiend she is exempt
from contracts and as such could be
still killed by the devil
power scoffs before cheerily asking and
annoyed dingy if he wants to wrestle the
group wait in the corridor nearby the
approaching wall of flesh pondering the
issue of starvation aki offers to use
the sword however hamina refuses his
suggestion
as a rai returns to their room he
discovers power has eaten all of their
food even still she attempts to blame
denji kabini then appears and in a
paranoid delusional state accuses power
of being the one trapping them as a riot
attempts to calm her down she accuses
him of siding with the fame and working
with the devils he tries to deny her but
she still attacks him as a ride begins
to scream out of fear the devil in the
hallway suddenly grows lunging at the
three still in the corridor the devil
chases them through the eighth floor
revealing that it grows in size based on
fear and that he the eternity devil will
be the one to kill the chainsaw devil
suddenly the rooms begin tilting as it
forces everyone to the opening of its
mouth demanding they give him dengue's
heart as the eternity devil looms
towards the group kabani and arai demand
they feed denji to it but aki instead
insists that he'll use the sword to get
them out however himino binds him
explaining that using such a weapon will
massively shorten his lifespan araya and
kabini lungit denchi however as the girl
goes to stab him aki jumps in the way
and blocks them getting stabbed instead
he explains that though he doesn't like
denji he needs all the allies he can get
to help him defeat the gun devil and so
he is willing to sacrifice his own
well-being in order to protect denji
shocked dingy asks power if she can stop
the bleeding to what she does otherwise
she won't have a human cook seeing aki's
injured state and a vision of her former
partner's graves himino collapses not
knowing what to do and suffering a
complete breakdown kabini tries blaming
dingy for the situation they are
currently in and frustrated as well then
she accepts his fate of being eaten but
informs the group he doesn't plan on
going down without a fight and if he
kills the devil he still wants his kiss
they wonder if he has a strategy but
dingy having noticed the devil screaming
in pain as amino attacked it earlier
realises that though the creature is
invulnerable it still feels pain
therefore then she plans to injure the
creature to the point of literally
making it kill itself the entire group
is left shocked by his devilish way of
thinking but as he leaps into the mouth
of the devil tearing his kill switch
dingy comments on aki's full heartiness
and remarks that if they escape because
of this then both of them are now even
with a smile on his face dingy drops
into the sinkhole of flesh and for a
brief moment the devil fully swallows
dengue making it seem as though he
simply died before he shatters the teeth
holding him inside its mouth then
exploding from the face of the eternity
devil in his complete chainsaw form he
begins slicing into the devil he begins
slicing into the devil and as the others
look on in horror at his transformation
the devil manages to break one of
dingy's arms but he immediately rips his
kill switch again restarting the
chainsaws and tearing into more of the
devil from above power comments on the
danger that denji is currently in
because he is losing blood fast his time
in the chainsaw form is reduced however
with even the devil screaming in him
saying he was weaker than he once was
then she still doesn't slow down the
eternity devil continues biting into
dingy resulting in dingy losing enough
blood to retract his chains or arms the
devil begins laughing telling him to die
until it is interrupted by dingy biting
it back and regaining his chainsaws
while fighting the devil dingy tells her
that even blood as gross as sewer water
would taste like strawberry jam if he
drank it while looking at him as himeno
looks on she has a flashback with an old
man in a graveyard in its the man
comments on how the best devil hunters
are those with a few screws loose and
the reason her past buddies have died
was because all of them were too sane
feeding the devils through their fear
the old man warns hamino of aki's
genuine intention to defeat the gun
devil and as he goes to leave he
recommends she train him as quickly as
possible for such an eventual fight
against the gun devil this entire
thought though left hemino troubled as
she didn't want to lose aki so she later
offers him a relaxed position in the
civilian sector but he flat out refused
her saying that he'll drink with her
whenever she wants but he'll never go to
the civilian sector
himino pinches a smoke of him and while
sitting there sadly comes to the
realization that the gun devil would
certainly kill aki not because they are
unable to beat it but because aki is
cool
serious and kind he's normal like
everyone else
but just as she goes to finish her
sentence she has a moment of hesitation
in the present she's looking down on
denji who continues to tear into the
eternity devil moments later though he
collapses of exhaustion which causes the
devil to begin celebrating however
himino uses the ghost devil to pull
denji's cord reawakening him then she
suddenly realizes that by drinking the
blood of the eternity devil he can
quickly recover his wounds and stamina
meaning he can continue attacking
indefinitely which causes hamino to
truly think that denji is damn crazy and
might actually be able to kill the gun
devil three entire days later now
exhausted and weak jimeno climbs into
bed next to aki and asks him to go
drinking but first she's gonna take a
nap as it is finally over as aki lays
there thinking that it's over below them
the eternity devil lays in tattered
pieces it reveals its core to denji
begging him to hurry up and kill it so
its suffering can end denji obliges
commenting what it's already over before
slashing the devil in half which dies
with a smile on its face finally
relieved from its pain
later on the group emerges from the
hotel with dingy bloodied and weary he's
super happy to have recovered a piece of
the gun devil but immediately afterwards
collapses from exhaustion ximena catches
him saying that her aki will take him to
the hospital then asking her in kabini
to report the events of the incident to
makima sometime later she suggests the
group will go drinking as they had
stated earlier in the hotel however aki
reveals kabini and arai are quitting the
bureau and suggests that the recent
experience was too dramatic for them
himeno argues though that it may be
instead due to their guilt over
attacking denji and not because they are
scared of devils aki brings up that even
himino though tried to kill denji so
eventually they agreed to drink sometime
later in the week on the prerequisite
that they could apologize to denji and
because mahima is leaving on a workshop
the week after as they stand there
smoking ximena asks about makima's
fascination with denji
saying that she normally travels all
over the place but lately she's been
hanging around didn't she and wonders if
it's because she knows her secret but
aki remains silent she then changes the
subject slightly asking if they should
get her drunk and try to get the real
answer out of her at the restaurant we
found the fourth division all chatting
happily one of the guys tells denji to
order more food but he is left
frustrated as he can't read the menu due
to his illiteracy when suddenly he's
reminded of himino's promise to a french
kiss ximena tells him she'll do it when
she's more intoxicated saying she feels
too sober she goes on to say that she'll
make it an intense one for him so please
forgive the team for trying to kill him
during their mission excited then she
happily forgives the others for trying
to kill him the group go around the
table introducing themselves most are
shocked to hear denji's young age of
only 16 and a riot introduces himself as
well as a 22 year old male who is
contracted with the fox devil aki
explains that the fox devil is friendly
with humans and a lot of devil hunters
have contracts with it
fushi an older hunter casually reveals
that his partner had died the day before
frightening the other young hunters who
ask if recruits die that easily they are
told that they get all the devils that
their civilian hunters couldn't handle
so people in their line of work often
drop like flies hemino now more drunk
makes flirtatious comments towards denji
and he suddenly grows more excited when
he learns that himeno often starts
kissing people when drunk
suddenly makima arrives then she
immediately grows flustered and
uncertain as to whether he wants to kiss
himino or try and wait for makima then
she begins to panic desperately wanting
to kiss amino whilst not wanting to kiss
her in front of mahima he tries to drive
the conversation in a different way
saying he found one of the gun pieces
aki interrupts wondering why devils with
gun pieces are appearing this frequently
and simply why the eternity devil
targeted denji he questions mahima about
her interests in denji however after
finishing her first class she called he
tells him that she'll tell them if they
can drink it out of her everyone
continues drinking until most have
passed out or left only makima seems
completely unaffected by the alcohol
asking for more instead over the other
side of the room power begins boasting
about her high iq but after she realizes
that it's a pretty normal one she
continuously lies and increases its
height and an effort to match the
ever-increasing smartness in the room
suddenly himino grabs denji from behind
and kisses him deeply danger is
concerned by makima watching but begins
to focus on the warmth in his mouth he
at first assumes a tamino's tongue
before moving back and realizing she had
vomited in his mouth the table will
react differently with power worriedly
stating that denji's childhood
malnourishments means he would swallow
anything for the nutrients instantly
just as she predicted dingy swallows the
vomit a flashback shows denchi and
pachita rummaging for food through a
dumpster they see a group of rats facing
on a pile of vomit to which dingy mocks
them not believing any creature could
stoop that low cutting back to the
restaurant awry comforts dingy in a
toilet cubicle as then she vomits into a
bowl noting the upset look on his face
he says that hamino needs more
self-control while he helps him orie
tells him how jealous he is of his devil
hunting abilities annoyed though then
she points out that he still has vomit
in his mouth from his first kiss
questioning what exactly he's jealous of
causing a rye to chuckle
later on the group will leave the
restaurant makima asks where dinji is
and fushi states that he left with
himeno on his back moments later in
another location dingy awakens in a bed
asking for water i still intoxicated
hamino appears and kisses him again
revealing that they are in her apartment
she complains to him asking what he and
aki see in mahima and calls her a
as she lies down next to denshi she
leans in and asks him whether he wants
to do it with her
dingy agrees to have that sicky time
with himino and she starts undressing
him however as she begins to take off
his pants she stops when she finds a
dirty lollipop in his pocket during the
time back at the restaurant while then
she was in a demotivated mood after the
vomit kiss makima took him outside for
some fresh air and buys some various
medicines to help with a sickly feeling
upset then she comments on how poor his
first kiss was expressing a worry that
all future kisses will remind him of the
taste of bath
makima sucking on a cold lollipop though
offers it to him telling him he probably
won't be able to forget the taste of
vomit for the rest of his life but not
to worry as he is going to experience
all kinds of tastes from now on until he
dies for starters this will be his first
indirect kiss and that is the taste of a
cola flavoured chopper chub back in the
present denji holds the lollipop staring
at it while hamino has passed out behind
him then she apologizes to vegeta having
refused to sleep with hamino stating
that he wants to wait for miss mahima to
be his first
so until he kills the gun devil he will
wait ximena wakes him in the morning and
cheerily offers him breakfast
now out on the balcony ximena tells him
she doesn't remember anything from the
previous night and asks if she forced
herself on him denji informs her he
refused her advances as he's saving
himself for mahima and she expresses her
relief as she didn't want to get
arrested for sleeping with a minor she
asks whether dingy is serious about
liking mahima despite her poor
personality dingy reaffirms this by
stating that he likes crap and himino
happily offers to help the two get
together the two agree upon a top secret
alliance whereby she will aid him in
return for him helping her get with aki
then she curiously asks what she likes
about aki to which she says that it's
his looks and because of this a very sly
looking dingy says that he's in on the
alliance
happy hamino tells denji they are now
friends rather than co-workers and
invites him aki and power to visit any
time
meanwhile makima and another devil
hunter sit on a train 30 minutes outside
of kyoto the two of them talk about the
food they will buy when they arrive at
the station
afterwards as my thinks of the night
before a group of passengers all around
them suddenly begin opening bags and
pulling out guns then proceeding to
shoot the two hunters until they are
obviously dead one of the assassins then
speaks repeating this is sea team this
is c team commence operation
[Music]
you